you know hello Paul Feig welcome back
Jim Sam hello my dear how are you you
know what I'm always happy when I'm here
yeah very well quaffed yes well you know
you know I saw a picture of you I saw
some pictures of your apartment yeah no
in yeah I know I'm an architecture
digest yeah I mean I have to tell you it
looks exhausting so it's very loud
it's very bright there it's it's a lot
of turquoises and Pink's yeah I see
Thanks
it's me yeah like me I'm loud and bright
I guess so we're in New York yeah that's
right Midtown not big at all it's only a
one-bedroom oh it's actually quite small
it's a little jewel box as we say who
designed it somebody wonderful hey
designer yes a designer yeah no it was
one of these places where we were
looking for a new place and I walked in
and I loved everything so much I said
just walk away literally leave
everything from the books to the glasses
to all the furniture oh I just do what
you want to do any apartment yeah I love
that I just it's very garish it's there
it is for those of you listening on the
radio they didn't matter
she's very colorful yeah let's weed out
a link to the Architectural Digest
because it really was funny when when I
looked at it I was like that is very
Paul Feig like you must have spent a lot
of time like picking out the furniture
in Baja and then it says nope that was
somebody else's stuff somebody's we were
like I need your whole life yeah I like
a little outdoor space that's that was
the big big thing yeah it's got this big
Terrace and we could have like the
dinner dinner parking so there we have
that's nice Jim and Sam you have to come
over for dinner party delighted and you
don't understand will show up tonight no
door space - I've had people over once
in a year and a half that's the thing I
don't entertain yeah I know we have like
a guest house at our house in LA and
like we never invite anybody yeah a lot
of people who saw your special on
Netflix said the same thing I figured
something salt was coming that
particular I got your back Jim I will
not thank you yeah and you were great
thank you I do
do you have you were you glad when
Architectural Digest came around because
it seems like that's the type of a place
yeah that you kind of want the world to
know about like look at the character
yeah the apartment that I have right
yeah well we gotta I was like how do we
kind of
this to the world and that make they
came around but it was yeah it's really
cool I mean it's it's it is ridiculous
but everything in my life is kind of
ridiculous that's why I like it looks
like something that Willy Wonka design
yeah
gene Wilder colors yeah no I I really
just you know what is is very hey bright
and happy I'm really affected by light
and all that so like your studio is
might be too dark for me I see yeah
what's your favorite place in the house
to go the bathroom yeah mine is yours
heated no no but the floor is heated
floors heated heated seat I had the
thing that shot the water up but it's
broken
in the toilet the whole thing that comes
out and that you shoots the water up
when you miss the Japanese one where you
can program all the different things
yeah but I don't get too involved
default settings I hit the button and I
just try to position so it doesn't shoot
up and hit me in the chin yeah good warm
toilet seat rules oh yeah I get more
work done on the toy you do I can't tell
you how many things I've created my life
on the toilet a lot of my haters would
agree with that do you have a that's
great yeah we introduce it's an
all-female cast for the new Apocalypse
Now oh those are amazing
those are great yeah well we have one
toilet this is a toilet dog yeah it's a
Nepal one toilet back in LA that's very
low and so that kind of does what a
squatty potty would do but a high toilet
is not a good no it's good it's bad for
you yes time do you spend in the New
York apartment probably about 20 percent
of my time mostly in LA just because
that's where my company is so it's okay
if it's a small place because coming us
yeah you're here but I'm dying to move
here full time
you like it better here yeah do you feel
more creative here I'm the briefs times
him in LA I'm just a lump I don't do
anything at least here I work no it's LA
you're just in your car all the time so
you kind of here you can you can just
you can find creativity because you're
just getting all this you know
input and and yes stimulus but in LA is
like okay where am I going to you know
go to find something so right you can't
just kind of there's no wandering in LA
no you know and you picked up by the
cops if you wander and what do you I
know you've been asked about guardians
of the galaxy and you said you don't
know infringed on another person's
project what do you think they do with
some
how do they fix that because now the
actors are rebelling like I don't know I
think they really got themselves into
kind of a mess yeah you know that's what
that is James's vision and he kills it
and you know whatever you think about
what he did in the past which I don't
you know I don't like what's kind of
jokes but no that's that's his thing
it's so funny like I announced you know
I don't want to do this and all these
guys wrote you better not do it it's
like I said no I you know when you when
somebody's got a vision for something
that's just that overrides everything
and then you know somebody can come in
look he's done - so he's set the world
but I was think it's a whole aesthetic
what's the strategy say you're a young
director right who kind of is like you
can't turn down because there are
directors who couldn't turn down that
opportunity's a huge you know so what is
the strategy is it to be like okay I'm
gonna try to just stick to James's
vision and not upset the way of things
is it I'm gonna move in another
direction because there's no avoiding
the fact that James isn't here well you
need to be reverent to what came before
but you know look you do have to if
you're gonna take it you do have to put
your stamp on it yeah but you know he
established such a specific world that
it's really hard to stray from that you
couldn't can't suddenly come in and just
change the whole look and change all the
music and all of it yeah yeah and also
like the I mean the the dialogue in it
like the way the characters speak I mean
there's scenes that don't necessarily
there aren't needed for narrative yeah
but are needed for character development
that like only James would be able to
yeah do know it's it's I mean it's you
know moviemaking is such a it doesn't it
seems like it's a big thing but you
don't realize like how much the director
puts the stamp on every because we you
know we just decide everything basically
and then you have really talented people
coming to make it better but ya know
it's a very personal thing you know as
much as you're known as a director
writer pretty as a creator I would
realize we're having a conversation
about you in the office the other day
and I realized that you as an actor have
made - as an a you performed in two of
my top five films really that's right
Oh which ones can you guess that thing
you do
that would be what role isn't the other
heavyweights every way so yes yes I was
honored to be a both of those I'd
forgotten that you were in that thing
you do which isn't a slight to you I
mean no
see that's Tom Hanks movie right to make
it's great it's such a sweet movie yeah
you yeah you play DJ and that's when
it's also like I feel like that was the
first time that you were in that context
and I was like oh his voice is perfect
to play a DJ like it would never have
occurred to me yeah no thanks well I
went for the very hey everybody all the
bagel oh well yeah I I always thought I
was gonna end up in radio actually
because I love I love radio and I think
I had I stayed in Detroit I probably
would have just you know what do you
love that is it the freeform or do you
like the structure of certain types
radio or do you like more conversation I
just like the free no I like just the
conversational just being able to be on
and create a world where you don't have
to create the visual for it you know it
was funny like growing up I listened to
see klw which was the big AM station in
Detroit in Canada and I just had such an
image of what what was happening in
radio you know you would hear the DJ so
I had an image what he looked like
I used to think I was a dumb as a kid I
thought whenever you hear a song that
the bands were there playing so I was
like wow I can't believe the Beatles are
are playing so you just can't you can
create so much without visuals it's
funny now that I do movies you know it's
all about creating the visual but there
is something nice about going like let's
just kind of theater the mind I got in
trouble sorry I got in trouble one time
when I was a kid like I was grounded for
something I had done prior in school so
they made me only no TV I only could
listen to the radio so my grandmother
turned me on to these radio mystery
stories and I've survived on them for a
few months and they were actually pretty
good they're really fun I mean it's fun
to listen to some of those old things I
mean back yeah also back when Detroit
was writing like radio plays just cuz
that's the only thing I knew I could
actually produce because I had a you
know tape recorder
it's also so great to do radio like this
cuz it's really the only sort of
creative medium where you can just do it
then be done like it's a three-hour show
make you three hours to do yeah and
that's it here it is you know right now
yeah and that's that but it means so
much because you become such friends
with you know like I'm I love all the
people I listen to on the radio like I
feel like Howard Stern is my friend
right I feel like you guys are my friend
because I hear you all the time in it if
it is such an intimate thing especially
in LA where you're in your car all the
time you are your only friends because
you're stuck in traffic all the time
yeah so thank you for being our friends
our pleasure that's what we you don't
always get that kind of feedback on
yeah I guess not not everybody
appreciate some times yeah but they just
say instead of thanks for being our
friends they say kill yourself yeah I
get a lot of those oh they love me the
internet loves me I look forward all the
great tweets I gotta get after this
appearance do you check it or no yeah I
run through it just because I'm always
kind of curious because there's a there
so what I find was social media there's
there's so many nice people who contact
you that it's worth kind of going like
all right there's a jerk and then you go
past them and you you I guess in the
situations that you are in you develop a
skin that's thick enough to handle it
and then the next thing that you do if
it's less than that it's so easy you're
like I've dealt with so much worse like
this is hold I could do this but I was
so unprepared for the first time and
when the Ghostbusters thing happened I
just was not prepared at all people
critical oh they were lovely
no I cuz I've had such a lovely you know
relationship with the internet before
that and then it was just it was so bad
that I reacted really poorly and now I
realize oh what a dummy like I should
have just you know take it oh but it's
so personal it comes in your phone it's
looking like somebody breaking into your
house and like screaming at you right
you're not they're not people weren't ya
supposed to have that kind of accent by
a magazine to read it now it's exactly
notification you some right threat it's
just that guy with no responsibility to
anything it's just what I'm in the
paradise of sitting on my toilet and
somebody yells in their phone it's
literally like they broke in now this is
a simple favor Asian theatres Friday
will show you here to promote yeah
that's an actual thriller yeah it's a
straight-up thriller but it's fun I call
it a frill er a fun thriller because
yeah it's very Hitchcock E and not that
I'm such a great director it's just in
that world of work remember his movies
were like suspenseful and in mystery but
they were also fun and they had kind of
fun side characters and you would still
laugh and be scared at the same time and
so that's when this one has its really a
but it's a thriller first and foremost
cuz I love the thriller genre it's my
favorite was it how did you know it was
time to go into thriller mode because
you know I mean you made such a career
over the last since well I mean before
bridesmaids but bridesmaids hit so huge
and then everything after that has been
gravy in terms of comedy right yeah I
mean for me it's just
when a project comes in or when an idea
strikes and this was the this case it
was a script that came in we got sent
this my company got sent this because
the studio that had it had it was a book
that then they had bought the book and
they hired this great writer Jessica
chars her to do the script for and then
they sent it to us when they got the
script because they said we don't know
what this is we don't know if this is a
comedy is it a drama it's bananas and so
they said maybe you can produce it so we
read it and I was like actually want to
direct this because I saw the potential
to make it really fun and you just kind
of checked all the boxes for me so how
do you how do you make that
determination because I don't think
people really get who aren't in the
business the difference between director
and producer totally like if you're a
producer does that mean like yeah I'd
like to kind of have a little thumbprint
on this but just kind of put things in
motion versus director is hands-on you
well is a producer you put it together
so you kind of go like okay well yeah we
like this here's my thoughts on the
script oh you know what director would
be good for this let's get this guy oh
these actors I think they would be you
know interesting but then once you get a
director you're kind of like okay let's
get their vision but will kind of
oversee and just make sure their things
are running smoothly but when you're the
director you you do everything so right
like you're gonna do all the cast I mean
it's a director you're just in charge of
everything that happens on the screen
but if the worst that when a producer
wants to have more input than they
should
oh no which does happen to some guy like
I don't know how much control you like
there's certain guys that get their own
final cut like you know or they you know
like Scorsese just bite hard for people
to tell us anything right but you know
do you ever have to push back and go
like look I get it but that's not a good
idea I used to have to I mean
fortunately now my company my producing
partner Jesse Henderson and i--i we we
our producers so sometimes you get a
project that there's another producer
already on but they just come in as
partners with us sure but yeah in the
old days I was always it was always a
battle with your producers because to me
but you know like you work with the
great producers about great producer is
awesome you know legette Abbott ah when
I worked Jud he's you know he's great
yes they do a great producer what they
should do is protect your vision and and
kind of hold off the studio because the
studio is always gonna come rushing
right with their stuff but there's other
producers who just yeah like you say
they want to get their hands on it and
as a filmmaker you're just trying to all
I want to do is get the approval of the
studio and a lot of times a producer is
like this middle purse
who then you're like wait why do I have
to take your note because I want to just
get to their note right the one that
matters and sometimes you'll have
producers give you notes and then the
studio gives you notes against theirs
and it's a whole mess well you look at
like you the I think editors are really
underrated yeah because I've watched the
apocalypse now the uncut one and then
you see the cut one and you're like
every cut what made sense yeah
the editor dries giant hunks out that
were boring it didn't fit or I don't
give a [ __ ] about and it was a perfect
the fact that they chopped all that
stuff out yeah well I mean that's the
dangerous thing about a director's cut
because a lot of times it's just it's it
just has stuff that doesn't need to be
in there but but you know sometimes
that's the editor sometimes that is the
studio having great notes sometimes it's
a good producer or sometimes it's the
director going like okay we got to do it
we have to make you know boil this down
but that's why I do so many test
screenings because that to me is you
know I don't kind of care what anybody
else's opinion is other than the
audience and so you know I can argue
with a producer or studio all day but
like if I put in from an audience and
they don't like some moment or they
think with some moment as hilarious that
nobody else likes I'm like well they
they win like no I don't care what
what's a really hard scene that you had
to cut that you didn't want to cut in a
film there must be one that you like I
love that scene and had to come out I
had a dance number in this movie that's
coming out now that I just absolutely I
just want to do a flash mob scene and I
love you know anyway we had a whole joke
about it and everything it was just kind
of a fun way to end the movie but it
just I I can't give anything away it was
just basically it was about two two
characters having some kind of a
resolution and and by no fault of the
actors just because the the audience
liked this one character so much they
didn't want that resolution for these
two characters huh so but you know I all
day this huge dance number with all the
cast and everything so but it'll be on
the deep we don't like this how either
you you kind of kind of volley with us
yeah I'm a big Bollywood I'll be honest
at the end of some don't hate is that so
I got a little teary-eyed
it's the greatest amazed I ho yeah like
that yeah there's a couple I mean when I
was in Syracuse and going to film
classes and stuff that was the exposure
that I had to Bollywood movies and
there's there there's actually some
really good Bollywood stuff I mean the
dance numbers in Bali the modern
Bollywood movies look at the
the best shot things you've ever seen in
your life my wife is a Bollywood fanatic
and so we that's all we do is watch
those they're the movies are a little
long for my taste like your hours long
because ever do just wants to stay in
the air-conditioning over there but oh
is that right yeah oh yeah camp out all
day but but I'm just blown away by some
of those dance numbers I'm not a big
dance we only have a couple minutes left
- I'm not a big dance number fan unless
it really that's why I don't like
musicals because they dance and sing too
much yeah like a little a little dancing
and singing yeah sure like an urn thing
exactly an urn thing but when every line
is dancing like I'm one of the few
people didn't like lame is and love I
know he loved to play love the movie or
css I do I am kind of dying to do a
musical but I but I hear you Jimmy I
mean that it's the hard thing that kind
of hit the right tone we're right you
don't want to put up people who don't
like musicals but you want to make
people who like him happy when I I feel
like a master question bridesmaids that
might have changed everything but I did
feel like for a while coming off of
freaks and geeks and when Jed did like
40 year old virgin and some of the early
stuff that he started to get really
successful within film that you guys
were kind of attached with everything
and when you would be doing something
his name would come up and vice versa
yeah did that get bothersome at any
point no I mean we you know we were like
brothers we love each other and we're so
in sync creatively but then there's
stuff I want to do that he doesn't want
to do and vice versa and so you know
what we you know I learned so much from
him and I think I think I gave him a lot
also and then it was just kind of fun to
go off on our own but we always kind of
support each other and stay in contact
but you know yes yeah it's weird like
you kind of start to go down different
paths right and for me I'm just so into
like genres which that isn't necessarily
his thing he loves with these really
character based you know you know more
personal things and I like kind of
taking a small personal story and then
putting it into a genre and trying to
play it big or play it for some other
effect I'm very much looking forward to
a simple thing yes thank well I got us I
mean Anna Kendrick and Blake Lively are
so amazing in this movie you're not
going to believe it lake live if you've
never seen her like this before because
she's plays kind of this
villainous character and then Anna
Kendrick is you know always wonderful
and then on top of it we've got Henry
Golding the star of crazy rich Asians oh
yeah yeah he's our he's our leading man
and he's so spectacular and one of the
nicest people you've ever met that
worked out well though and that great
when they do a hit right before yeah
yeah this place on that really I know
judge me rice and they're like please
don't let that movie bomb